yeah we're a bit late to the party
Google Dean's been out for a while but
it follows all nicely from on your
network talks let's talk about how it
works
Google deep dream is a strange computer
program that outputs kind of psychedelic
trippy images this is one of the
Google's gallery and it's some kind of
strange and what is it we don't know
kind of strange this sort of a viaduct
here and that looks like a fountain and
some grass weird sort of artistic image
but generated entirely by a computer now
at the time this came out most people
were having lots of fun playing with
this and playing with online generators
but no one we know really talked about
the down how it worked kinda looks like
sort of digital Salvador Dali doesn't it
does a bit yeah and I think we quite
interesting - really quite like the idea
that computers can do art in some way
for what it were it's not quite art yet
I don't think but we're you know it's a
bit of fun it also has an interesting
implications as to what the neural
network is doing underneath that we
talked about a bit during the video
where we looked into a network and sort
classifying digits this is a similar
kind of thing where you can see but the
lower-level layers are doing some things
and higher-level layers are doing other
things so let's try and break down what
it's doing and then we can see some fun
images over and of myself now Google's
Google net which is the name for
Google's network that they release in I
think 2012 as part of the image net
competition is quite complicated right
they have these modules of groups of
convolutional layers called inception
modules which is a very cool name for
something which is probably not quite as
cool as that but it's a cool name the
idea is you go deeper and deeper into
the network and you get more and more
powerful classification out of it okay
but at its core it's still a
classification network so it's saying
what is this a picture of is a picture
of account right hundreds ain't
confident features a cat definitely oh
no it could be a dog right so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to draw Network
but I'm going to draw my sort of
standard multi-layer network but it's
got nothing to do with convolutions and
nothing to do with Google net because
it's easier to visualize so I'm
oversimplifying it but on the other hand
the same things apply to this small
network I'm going to draw as to the big
network so remember that we have some
input neurons here and then we have some
intermediate neurons and then finally
our output neurons now if people
back to the videos we did on this this
new on here calculates a weighted sum of
all of these neurons and this one
calculates a weighted sum of all of
these neurons so if we were going back
to our house analogy right this one here
could be number of windows this could be
square footage this could be if it's got
a pool or not right and this is taking
some combination of those things and
trying to start to work towards a price
for a house and this one takes some
combination of those combinations and
starts working towards the price per
house now when we talked about
convolutional networks these newer ones
that were placed with image convolutions
like Sobel edge detection z' and other
things right where the actual
convolutions and silver learned so the
early layers are going to be finding
lines and corners and things like this
later on we're going to start to find
objects boxes circles things that have
multiple lines and corners as part of
them and finally as a top we start to
move towards actual objects we're trying
to classify cats and dogs and bikes and
then finally we get an output that
lights up if it's a cat that's the key I
mentioned this very briefly in a video
and I'm going to mention it again very
briefly because back propagation is not
for a computer file video there's a lot
of detailed analysis of backpropagation
online for people who are interested in
it right it's very mathematically
complex it talks a lot about partial
derivatives and multivariate calculus
and things like this we won't be doing
any of that in this video so please
don't turn it off right but the idea is
that if we put an image in at this point
we can calculate these weighted sums and
we can propagate it through and get a
value out that says how much of a cat is
in this image is essentially what we're
doing when we actually want to train
this network to do something what we do
is we know we're looking for a cat so we
try and change these weights to better
predict it so we have something called a
cost function here C and what we're
trying to do is we're trying to work out
how we affect C by changing this
particular weight here so it's a
relationship between the weights and the
cost function now when we train a neural
network what we do is we try and
minimize this cost function so the cost
function might be something like
prediction accuracy or Euclidean
distance or some sort of softmax right
but the point is that this gives us a
value of how good our guess is and then
we alter all our weights going backwards
to say let's change these weights a bit
so that that error goes down and we get
a little bit closer to the right
all right so we go forward to get our
prediction we calculate the area and we
propagate the over backwards so that's
all the background you really need to
know how Google deep Veeam works what
Google deep dream does is forget the
cost function completely we've already
trained the network what we want to do
is maximize these values here all these
values here so think about if this is a
picture of a cat right so I'm putting in
a picture of a cat here then what's
going to happen is it's going to create
a way to sum and then one of the cat
neurons is going to light up right but
also if you think about this layer if
we're working our way backwards it might
be because this one lit up which is
maybe there's ears and this one lit up
which is maybe paws and maybe this one
lit up because here was a few lines in a
row and this one is sort of furry
texture or something you know and we're
getting lower and lower level as we go
through and in the end it's because this
one lit up which is edges and this one
lit up which is corners in a certain
place the values in here influence the
values here and here and here and here
and then end up converging on our thing
so what we want to do to make our Google
deep view images is change the image to
make these bigger right so if this is
the amount of ear in our image if we can
just make that as big as possible we can
say more ears please if it's a bit of
ear going on there
but I want more I want more ears I want
more paws I want more bits of cat so
instead of minimizing this cost function
we're maximizing the sum of these or
squared some of these let's not do any
more maths right let's look at some
pictures I have my landscape image now
if it's looking very boring to you it's
because I haven't passed this for Google
D dream yet right but what I do is I
pass this input into the Google deep
dream and for every area in the image it
starts to light up some of these newer
ones because maybe or vobis isn't a
picture of a cat maybe there are some
kind of catty features in it you know
like the edge of a leaf might be kind of
the same shape as an ear or this texture
of this grass kind of the same texture
as fur so some of the same neurons are
going to light up all right so what we
do is we then try and make those bigger
by altering our input image okay so just
like we would try and train our network
to get better we train our image to get
better to be more of these features now
of course this network is trained also
things other than cats
so anything that looks at all plausible
it's going to try and maximize that
effect so this is a picture I ran
through it
here okay we've done some strange things
in the sky here we've got the kind of
moves of buildings appearing and then
down here we've got some animals
appearing and I don't know what that is
I'm put a Dalek and then this weird
animal here if we zoom in on that means
anybody's guess what kind of animal that
is but this is what's so cool about
Google daydreams you don't what you're
going to get and it's going to depend on
your input image so you know the
features that it found an input image
all that feature looks a bit like a
bunch of lines which in turn look a bit
like the edge of a cat's head make it
look more like that and if you keep
doing this process it starts to converge
on weird animals but have interesting
features so is that multiple iteration
yes I think it does about 40 iterations
by default so it tweaks a weights of the
image 14 times an actual fact Google
deep dream does it at different scales
as well but we've sort of brushed over
that because it's not hugely important
but it runs a small version of image
first makes it a bit bigger runs it
again makes it a bit bigger and runs it
again so you can then take this image
and put it back into the front and make
it more I want more of these weird
shapes and weird animals so I take this
image and I put it in and I get
something but really weird so it's the
same but but just more of it it bears no
resemblance really I mean there's a tiny
bit of tree left here but this it bears
very little resemblance to our original
image
apart from this generic area of ground
and the sky but on the other hand we've
got all kinds of this there's a weird
karma peering here and some actual
full-on buildings starting to appear
because later on in this network some of
these neurons are going to be
representing building shapes and so it's
trying to make it more building shape
what's this for right why are we doing
this I mean that's a question doctor at
Google because I'm not entirely sure but
now it's there are two things what is
fun right so mostly it's fun now most
people aren't interested in what neural
network is doing underneath they like
cool trippy images and one of the
problems with neural networks is that
they are blackbox so we design them with
an architecture and we run them when
they get out of 80% accuracy on some
task and that's very good and then we
say know more about it we now have a
program that can classify these things
at 80% accuracy in many ways we don't
really care about
how I did it if it does it but if we
want to improve these things beyond 80%
and beyond 90% and get them better and
better it's a good idea to try and
understand what's going on underneath so
there are some papers out there Google
are working on it with other papers as
well but are trying to understand what
it is but the lowest layers of a network
of doing and the highest layers of the
network of doing four different tasks
intuitively the lowest layers are edges
and things and as we go up hierarchical
groups of these things so buildings and
so on so one thing you can do is you can
instead of maximizing this layer which
represents very high level objects we
can maximize one of the layers down here
which maximizes edges and things so
here's a here's another picture of
Google deep dream that I've maximized a
lower layer okay so you can see but
instead of starting to form objects it's
now just starting to form patterns of
lines and textures and that's because
that's the only thing that's described
that with lower level of a network so
now we're on Van Gogh yeah so yeah
Impressionism like this is much better
than I can paint as well the idea is the
lower layers of a network of doing
things like this and with higher layers
of a network and looking for more
complex objects that's basically what
only one network does this network has
been trained on somewhere around a
thousand classes objects so cats dogs
bikes people buildings and so on this
network that I showed at the beginning
is trained only on buildings which is
why many of the things that have been
generated in it looked like buildings
often some of the objects you see start
to look very similar so you've got a
building here that looks like a building
and another one that looks kind of
similar with this would be spiked on and
that's because the network's been
trained on certain objects and these
objects get a good response and then it
make maximizes those things so the
question was then what if I want to
generate an image that makes this look
more like a cat specifically a cat
rather than just cats and dogs and
buildings and bikes and all these
different things so what we do is we put
a cat image into it into the network and
we find out which of these light up for
a cat specifically a cat right and then
we instead of maximizing all of them we
maximize only those ones
okay so we're basically saying now more
of it please but more of only the
specific interesting cat ones
I chose cat because people on the
internet have a lot of pictures of cats
they're very easy to obtain so I put in
a picture here's a picture of some cats
I put in so when I put this into the
image into the neural network it's going
to classify this as a cat or multiple
cats and it's going to do that by
finding combinations of features but
look like cats so if I pin down the
learning to do this I can start to make
my image look more like a cat so you can
see there's some eyes have appeared
there's a kind of nose here that looks
let's face it's not really a cat but
it's more of a cat than the landscape
was it's a pretty weird image all things
considered and this is a high level if
we do the same thing for a lower layer
we can't get all that hierarchical sort
of ears plus eyes + nose we can only get
the low level things so we can say do
this one which is almost entirely fur
and eyes right so you can see that the
clouds kind look a bit like fur so it's
made them look more like that and the
eyes of all down here so this is a
different kind of image that we produced
by trying to make it look a bit like a
cat but only at a low level so you know
what are the low level features that
make a cat ok how strange
and finally you can do it for people so
I put in a picture of some people's
faces and out we get is a incredibly
weird picture of sort of weird hybrid
baby things that kind of gives me
nightmares you could argue in some ways
we're getting an intuition about what
the lower levels do and what the high
levels do predominantly it's just for
fun there are other papers that do
outputting of Network layers and trying
to work out what it is but usually I was
doing but in this way it just kind of
generates cool images so if you want to
use Google deep theme you just need an
input image and maybe a reference image
like a cat to target it towards but
really you don't need much more than
that and then you can just get going on
it
is it a website or something is right so
no so actually it's it's Python code
that goes into cafe which is a deep
learning library so that's how I
generated these images but people have
obviously put a website front-end on
this so it's very easy to find websites
that do the same thing but in actual
fact it will just be running the source
code back behind the scenes if you look
food a source code actually not very
long because this process of back
propagation is already coded up in these
libraries so what you need to do is tell
it instead of Mac
minimizing this see we want to maximize
the value of these things and you just
change a few numbers around and send it
backwards through the network it's no
not it sounds complicated but really
actually it isn't that complicated once
you want to actually look at the code
you can start to see this quite easily
what we're here is a piece of 16 male
film you can see that actually you've
got lots and lots of individual images
and each of those images we refer to as
a single frame and when you project you
this fear we literally shot